- Selamat datang kembali di Understanding Quantum Information and Computation.
Nama saya John Watrous dan saya adalah Technical Director for
Education di IBM Quantum.
Ini adalah pelajaran ketujuh dari seri ini dan di pelajaran ini kita akan membahas masalah phase estimation dan bagaimana kita bisa menyelesaikannya
dengan komputer kuantum.
Kita kemudian akan menerapkan phase estimation pada masalah faktorisasi bilangan bulat, yang kita bahas di pelajaran sebelumnya.
Yang akan kita dapatkan adalah algoritma Shor, yang memungkinkan bilangan bulat difaktorisasi dengan biaya polinomial atau dalam waktu polinomial kalau kita mau
memikirkannya dari sisi waktu yang dibutuhkan daripada jumlah
operasi dasar yang kita perlukan.
Ini adalah mahkota dari
algoritma kuantum dalam suatu artian, dan meskipun faktorisasi bilangan bulat besar
mungkin punya kegunaan yang terbatas bagi kebanyakan orang, ini tetap menjadi salah satu bukti paling kuat yang kita punya untuk hipotesis bahwa komputer kuantum akan
menawarkan keunggulan yang luar biasa
dibanding komputer klasik. Berikut gambaran umum pelajarannya.
Kita akan mulai dengan definisi masalah phase estimation itu sendiri, kemudian kita akan membahas metode untuk menyelesaikan masalah ini
dengan komputer kuantum.
Kita akan lakukan satu per satu, dimulai dengan apa yang bisa
kamu anggap sebagai semacam pemanasan.
Dalam masalah phase estimation, tujuannya adalah mengaproksimasi
suatu bilangan real tertentu dan di bagian pemanasan ini
kita akan lihat bagaimana kita bisa mendapatkan
aproksimasi dengan presisi sangat rendah
untuk bilangan ini.
Ini tidak akan cukup
untuk faktorisasi ketika kita menerapkan solusi kita pada
masalah phase estimation ke faktorisasi bilangan bulat,
kita sebenarnya butuh aproksimasi dengan presisi yang cukup tinggi, tapi tetap berguna untuk mulai dengan semacam pemanasan ini
hanya untuk memahami
bagaimana keseluruhan hal ini bekerja.
Kita kemudian akan membahas masalah bagaimana kita bisa mendapatkan lebih banyak presisi, dan ini akan mengarah dengan sangat
alami ke operasi yang dikenal sebagai Quantum Fourier transform.
Kita akan melihat persis apa operasi ini dan bagaimana bisa diimplementasikan
dengan quantum circuit.
Dan begitu kita punya itu, kita akan bisa menerapkannya
pada phase estimation untuk mendapatkan prosedur umum dalam menyelesaikan masalah
dengan presisi sangat tinggi.
Kemudian di bagian terakhir pelajaran, kita akan lihat bagaimana solusi untuk
masalah phase estimation memungkinkan kita memfaktorisasi bilangan bulat secara efisien.
Dan secara spesifik yang akan kita dapatkan adalah algoritma Shor untuk
faktorisasi bilangan bulat, atau setidaknya sesuatu yang setara dengan algoritma Shor.
Cara kerjanya adalah kita pada dasarnya memberikan
diri kita batu loncatan, yaitu masalah lain yang disebut masalah order finding.
Dan khususnya kita akan lihat bagaimana kita bisa menyelesaikan masalah order finding menggunakan prosedur phase estimation dan kemudian kita akan lihat bagaimana
kita bisa memfaktorisasi bilangan bulat
dengan menyelesaikan masalah order finding. Kita akan mulai dengan kasus khusus dari sebuah teorema yang disebut Spectral theorem,
dan secara khusus kita akan fokus pada apa yang teorema ini ceritakan
kepada kita untuk matriks unitary.
Spectral theorem adalah
teorema yang sangat penting dari aljabar linear dan
analisis fungsional.
Ini menceritakan sesuatu yang menarik tentang bagaimana pemetaan linear tertentu bisa dinyatakan dalam bentuk tertentu, yang sering disebut sebagai
spectral decomposition,
yang berguna untuk banyak alasan.
Dan seperti yang saya bilang, kita akan fokus pada apa yang teorema ini ceritakan
kepada kita untuk matriks unitary.
Spectral theorem lebih umum dari ini. Ini tidak berlaku untuk semua matriks, tapi berlaku untuk kelas matriks
yang disebut matriks normal, yang mencakup semua matriks unitary maupun beberapa matriks
yang bukan unitary.
Tapi supaya sederhana, kita akan membatasi perhatian kita
pada matriks unitary untuk saat ini karena itulah yang kita butuhkan untuk
tujuan pelajaran ini.
Berikut pernyataan spectral theorem khusus untuk matriks unitary.
Misalkan U adalah
matriks unitary N kali N.
Yang teorema katakan
adalah bahwa pasti ada basis ortonormal dari
vektor, psi satu sampai psi N,
bersama dengan N bilangan kompleks
Lambda satu sampai Lambda N, semuanya berada di lingkaran satuan kompleks sehingga U bisa dinyatakan
seperti yang ada di persamaan ini.
Ini disebut spectral
decomposition dari U, seperti yang sudah saya sebutkan, dan sangat nyaman untuk mengetahui bahwa U bisa ditulis dengan cara ini.
Terkadang nyaman untuk memiliki vektor-vektor dan angka-angka ini ketika kita bekerja dengan
matriks unitary U tertentu, dan juga bisa sangat
berguna hanya untuk mengetahui
bahwa ekspresi seperti itu selalu mungkin sebagai cara untuk membuktikan hal-hal tertentu tentang matriks unitary misalnya.
Dalam pernyataan teorema ini, setiap angka ini,
Lambda satu sampai lambda N, ditulis dengan cara tertentu
sebagai E pangkat dua pi I kali theta di mana setiap theta
theta satu sampai theta N adalah bilangan real, dan
kita akan kembali ke cara penulisan
setiap angka ini
dalam sebentar.
Hal penting yang perlu diperhatikan
tentang vektor-vektor dan angka-angka ini adalah bahwa setiap vektor psi
K harus menjadi eigenvector dari matriks U dengan
eigenvalue yang sesuai lambda K.
Yang berarti bahwa kalau kita
kalikan psi K dengan U, yang kita dapatkan adalah lambda K kali psi K.
Jadi yang U lakukan pada setiap vektor ini adalah mengalikannya dengan angka yang sesuai lambda K.
Untuk vektor sembarang secara umum, ini bukan bagaimana U bekerja, tapi eigenvector itu istimewa.
Dan yang teorema ceritakan kepada kita adalah bahwa memang ada
basis ortonormal dari eigenvector-eigenvector ini.
Persamaan di bawah ini ngomong-ngomong, mengikuti dari ekspresi yang kita punya untuk U dari teorema, bersama dengan fakta bahwa
vektor-vektornya ortonormal.
WEBVTT
Kalau kamu kalikan
ekspresi U ke psi K manapun dan menggunakan ortonormalitas vektornya, kamu akan mendapatkan jumlah di mana
semua suku-sukunya nol
kecuali salah satunya, dan satu suku yang tersisa terlihat seperti ini.
Sekarang kita bisa mendefinisikan
masalah phase estimation.
Masalahnya agak
tidak biasa seperti yang akan kita lihat.
Kita diberi dua hal. Pertama, kita diberi deskripsi quantum circuit unitary,
yang beraksi pada N qubit
untuk suatu pilihan N, dan ketika kita bilang bahwa ini
adalah circuit unitary,
kita hanya bermaksud bahwa semua
gate-nya unitary, jadi tidak ada pengukuran
dalam circuit ini.
Kedua, kita diberi state N qubit psi, dan itulah bagian yang tidak biasa.
Kita sebenarnya punya
state kuantum sebagai input untuk masalah ini, dan itu satu salinan dari state ini.
Untuk semua masalah komputasional lain yang kita bahas dalam seri ini, inputnya bersifat klasik, baik dalam bentuk string
bit maupun sebagai black box.
Dan itu tidak mengherankan karena masalah komputasional
yang kita temui dalam kehidupan sehari-hari cenderung bersifat klasik,
karena itulah
masalah yang paling kita pedulikan.
Cara kamu bisa
memikirkan masalah ini adalah bahwa ini adalah sesuatu yang muncul atau kemungkinan muncul sebagai sub masalah.
Dan prosedur phase estimation yang akhirnya kita dapatkan adalah sesuatu yang
umumnya kita gunakan sebagai sub-rutin
di dalam komputasi yang lebih besar, kemungkinan untuk masalah klasik
yang kita pedulikan.
Nah, ini akan menjadi masalah dengan promise dan state psi bukan
sembarang state kuantum.
Kita dijanjikan bahwa psi adalah eigenvector dari operasi unitary U apapun yang circuit yang diberikan gambarkan.
Dan tujuannya adalah untuk menemukan atau
mengaproksimasi eigenvalue yang bersesuaian dengan eigenvector psi.
Mari kita nyatakan masalahnya
dengan sedikit lebih tepat.
Inputnya terdiri dari
quantum circuit unitary pada N qubit, yang bisa dikodekan sebagai string bit
menggunakan metode apapun yang kita sukai untuk mengkodekan deskripsi quantum circuit, bersama dengan state N qubit psi.
Kita bisa menyebut circuit itu dengan nama apapun yang kita mau, tapi yang benar-benar penting dalam konteks pernyataan masalah ini adalah operasi unitary itu sendiri
yang dilakukan ketika circuit dijalankan, dan operasi unitary itu
digambarkan oleh Matriks U.
Tapi kita tidak diberi U sebagai matriks, kita hanya diberi deskripsi quantum circuit yang mengimplementasikan U.
Promisenya, seperti yang sudah saya nyatakan, adalah bahwa psi adalah eigenvector dari U.
Jadi kalau kita menjalankan circuit kita pada psi, kita akan mendapatkan psi keluar dikalikan dengan eigenvalue-nya berapapun itu,
yang akan menjadi global
phase dalam situasi itu.
Dan akhirnya, output dari masalah ini adalah aproksimasi terhadap eigenvalue yang bersesuaian dengan psi, dan secara khusus kita mencari
aproksimasi terhadap bilangan real theta, antara nol dan satu, termasuk
nol, tapi tidak termasuk satu
yang memenuhi persamaan
yang ada di layar.
Untuk menjelaskan cara
memarameterisasi eigenvalue yang bersesuaian dengan psi, dan juga untuk memperjelas apa yang kita maksud dengan aproksimasi,
mari kita gambar
lingkaran satuan kompleks.
Kita bisa menempatkan angka satu, I,
negatif satu, dan negatif I di tempat biasanya dan kita bisa mempertimbangkan
suatu titik sembarang pada
lingkaran yang diparameterisasi oleh theta seperti yang ada dalam pernyataan masalah.
Ini adalah titik yang kita
dapatkan kalau kita mulai dari satu dan berputar sebesar sudut
dua kali pi kali theta, jadi sudutnya bukan
theta, tapi dua pi theta,
dan cara lain untuk memikirkannya adalah kalau kita mulai dari satu dan menempuh jarak dua pi theta pada lingkaran itu sendiri,
kita akan sampai ke titik kita, E pangkat
dua kali pi kali theta.
Setiap titik dalam lingkaran satuan kompleks bisa direpresentasikan dengan cara ini
untuk pilihan theta yang unik.
Dan itu karena kita mengelilingi
seluruh lingkaran saat theta bergerak dari nol ke satu, dan kalau kita pergi
semua jalan ke theta sama dengan satu,
kita akan kembali ke tempat kita
mulai di theta sama dengan nol, itulah kenapa kita menyertakan nol, tapi tidak menyertakan satu.
Hanya untuk memastikan bahwa setiap
titik pada lingkaran satuan kompleks bersesuaian dengan nilai theta yang unik dalam rentang yang kita pertimbangkan.
Ada berbagai cara
yang bisa kita bayangkan untuk mengaproksimasi nilai theta tertentu, tapi cara yang akan kita lakukan adalah mengaproksimasi theta dengan pecahan,
di mana penyebutnya
adalah dua pangkat M untuk suatu pilihan bilangan bulat positif M, dan pembilangnya adalah bilangan bulat y
antara nol dan dua pangkat M dikurangi satu.
Kamu bisa memikirkan ini sebagai aproksimasi m-bit terhadap theta kalau kamu mau, dan kita bisa menulis
angka ini dalam notasi biner
di mana kita punya titik biner diikuti oleh representasi biner
dari Y.
Saya bilang titik biner ngomong-ngomong
daripada titik desimal karena desimal berarti basis 10 dan saya sedang bicara tentang basis dua
di sini, tapi idenya sama.
Tapi bagaimanapun kita juga bisa
memikirkannya sebagai pecahan seperti yang
ada di layar.
Dan untuk lebih jelasnya, ketika kita memikirkan
aproksimasi dalam konteks ini, harus dipahami
bahwa nilai-nilai theta
WEBVTT
mendekati nol dan nilai-nilai theta mendekati satu sebenarnya berdekatan satu sama lain.
Jadi misalnya, kalau theta sama dengan 0,99 dan kita mengaproksimasi nilai
theta ini dengan nilai nol,
itu adalah aproksimasi yang cukup bagus dalam artian bahwa selisihnya
dalam satu per seratus dari nilai sebenarnya, ketika
kita melingkar kembali
dan kembali ke nol saat kita sampai ke satu.
Istilah modulo satu terkadang digunakan untuk menggambarkan situasi, di mana kita pada dasarnya
menyamakan theta sama dengan satu dengan theta sama dengan nol.
Intinya adalah bahwa kita benar-benar peduli tentang lokasi titik
E pangkat dua pi I theta pada lingkaran satuan,
dan memikirkan cara ini dalam mengaproksimasi theta masuk akal ketika kita memiliki tujuan itu.
Pernyataan masalah itu sendiri,
seperti yang ada di layar, tidak spesifik tentang seberapa bagus aproksimasi terhadap theta yang dibutuhkan,
tapi itu adalah sesuatu yang bisa kita sesuaikan tergantung pada kebutuhan kita.
Dalam beberapa situasi kita mungkin puas dengan aproksimasi presisi rendah
terhadap theta, dan dalam situasi lain kita mungkin menuntut
aproksimasi dengan presisi sangat tinggi, dan pernyataan masalah itu sendiri
bisa disempurnakan sesuai kebutuhan.
Selanjutnya kita akan lihat bagaimana kita bisa menyelesaikan
masalah phase estimation dengan komputer kuantum dan
kita akan mulai dengan pemanasan.
Ini bukan
solusi final kita untuk masalah ini.
Yang akan kita lakukan adalah memanfaatkan fenomena phase kickback untuk mencoba mempelajari sesuatu
tentang eigenvalue yang bersesuaian dengan eigenvector yang diberikan.
Ingat bahwa dalam
masalah phase estimation kita diberi deskripsi
quantum circuit unitary untuk operasi U tertentu,
dan yang kita lakukan pertama adalah
menggunakan deskripsi circuit ini untuk membuat circuit baru yang mengimplementasikan operasi controlled U seperti
yang digambarkan di layar.
Ini cukup sederhana untuk dilakukan. Yang bisa kita lakukan adalah menambahkan control qubit, yang digambarkan di
bagian atas diagram ini
dan menggunakan control qubit baru ini sebagai kontrol untuk setiap gate tunggal yang
ada dalam circuit kita.
Jadi semua gate diterapkan kalau control qubit ini disetel ke satu, dan tidak ada yang diterapkan kalau control qubit disetel ke nol,
Artinya kita akan
butuh versi controlled dari setiap gate yang
ada dalam circuit U, tapi kita tidak perlu memikirkan gate controlled baru ini
sebagai gate tunggal kalau kita tidak mau. Mereka bisa diimplementasikan
sebagai circuit kecil yang terbuat dari gate dari set gate apapun
yang kita pilih untuk digunakan. Dan begitu kita punya
versi controlled dari U, kita bisa mempertimbangkan untuk menjalankan circuit ini,
di mana kita pertama-tama menempatkan control qubit ke superposisi nol dan satu, menerapkan controlled U gate ke eigenvector sisi yang kita berikan,
dan kemudian menerapkan Hadamard gate
ke kontrol dan melakukan pengukuran.
Kita akan lihat kenapa masuk akal untuk melakukan ini saat kita melalui analisisnya, tapi bahkan sebelum kita masuk ke detailnya, kita bisa langsung melihat kesamaan
dengan algoritma Deutsche misalnya, di mana kita menerapkan
beberapa Hadamard gate dan mengukur sebagai cara
untuk secara efektif menyelidiki
apa yang dilakukan oleh operasi yang diberikan di sini.
Ini adalah unitary terkontrol
daripada query gate, tapi ada ide-ide yang sangat serupa yang dimainkan.
Jadi mari kita lihat apa yang dilakukan circuit itu.
State awal adalah eigenvector psi, ditensor dengan state nol
untuk control qubit,
menerapkan Hadamard gate pertama mengubah state dari
qubit atas ke state plus dan kita bisa mengekspansi seluruh
state seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini.
Kita kemudian menerapkan operasi controlled U dan yang dilakukannya adalah menerapkan U ke psi ketika control qubit disetel ke satu,
tapi tidak ketika disetel ke nol. Jadi kita mendapatkan state pi dua
yang tertulis di layar.
Kita bisa menyederhanakan state
menggunakan fakta bahwa psi adalah eigenvector dari U dengan eigenvalue e pangkat dua pi I theta.
Jadi kita mendapatkan eigenvalue itu mengalikan suku kedua, tapi bukan yang pertama.
Dan kita bisa menyederhanakan menggunakan bilinearitas
dari tensor product.
Jadi yang kita punya di sini adalah fenomena phase kickback, tapi kali ini terjadi untuk eigenvector psi sembarang dari operasi unitary U sembarang,
berbeda dengan operasi not yang diterapkan ke state minus lebih spesifiknya.
Jadi itulah state setelah operasi controlled U diterapkan.
Ngomong-ngomong, ada baiknya
meluangkan waktu untuk memperhatikan bahwa state dari N qubit bawah masih berupa eigenvector psi.
Yang sangat bagus karena itu
memberi kita kesempatan untuk menggunakannya lagi kalau kita mau.
Kemudian Hadamard gate kedua dilakukan dan inilah state yang kita dapatkan.
Dan saya tidak menunjukkan semua
detail derivasinya di sini, tapi kalau kamu menerapkan
Hadamard gate dan menyederhanakan, inilah yang seharusnya kamu dapatkan.
Jadi itulah state tepat
sebelum pengukuran.
Jadi kita bisa fokus pada state ini untuk melihat apa yang bisa kita pelajari
tentang theta dengan mengukur.
Dan kalau kita mengukur qubit
atas atau qubit paling kanan, inilah probabilitas yang kita dapatkan untuk dua hasilnya.
Dan di sini saya menggunakan
beberapa rumus dasar yang menghubungkan sinus dan kosinus
dengan eksponensial kompleks untuk menyatakan probabilitas-probabilitas ini
dalam bentuk sinus dan kosinus.
Secara khusus, probabilitas mendapatkan nol adalah kuadrat kosinus dari pi kali theta dan probabilitas mendapatkan satu
WEBVTT
adalah kuadrat sinus dari sudut yang sama. Dan ini masuk akal
karena kuadrat sinus ditambah kuadrat kosinus dari
sudut manapun sama dengan satu.
Jadi probabilitas-probabilitas kita
berjumlah satu seperti yang kita harapkan.
Dan berikut plot dari probabilitas-probabilitas ini sebagai fungsi dari theta.
Untuk lebih jelasnya, ini adalah plot dari
probabilitas-probabilitas itu sendiri bukan plot yang menggambarkan distribusi probabilitas tunggal misalnya.
Misalnya, kalau theta
sama dengan satu setengah, maka probabilitas bahwa
kita mendapatkan hasil satu yang digambar dalam warna ungu sama dengan satu
sementara probabilitas
mendapatkan hasil nol, yang digambar dalam warna biru, adalah nol.
Di sisi lain, kalau theta sama dengan satu
perempat atau tiga perempat, maka kita punya bahwa setiap dua hasil sama-sama mungkin.
Dan tentu saja untuk semua pilihan theta, jumlah probabilitasnya sama dengan satu seperti yang sudah kita amati.
Jadi kita tidak mengetahui dengan tepat apa
theta dari prosedur ini, tapi memang memberikan kita beberapa
informasi tentang theta.
Dan kalau kita bayangkan situasi di mana kita dijanjikan
bahwa theta sama dengan nol atau theta sama dengan satu setengah, prosedur ini akan memberitahu kita
persis mana dari dua
kemungkinan itu yang benar.
Jadi itulah cara sederhana yang bisa kita gunakan fenomena phase kickback untuk mempelajari sesuatu tentang eigenvalue.
Jadi bagaimana kita bisa mempelajari lebih banyak
tentang eigenvalue?
Nah, ini adalah situasi di mana kita bisa membiarkan
ketidaktahuan menjadi panduan kita.
Karena memang tidak terlalu
banyak hal yang bisa kita lakukan.
Kita tidak tahu banyak hal apapun
tentang eigenvector sin, dan kita juga tidak tahu
banyak tentang operasi U.
Kita punya circuit untuk U, tapi bisa saja itu
kekacauan yang mengerikan dan membingungkan yang tidak akan bisa kita pahami
dengan memeriksanya.
Tapi satu opsi alami adalah menjalankan circuit beberapa kali.
Khususnya, kita bisa mencoba melakukan persis hal yang sama yang baru saja kita lakukan, kecuali bahwa alih-alih menerapkan hanya satu operasi controlled U,
kita menerapkan operasi itu dua kali. Atau kita bisa menerapkannya berapa kali saja, tapi mari kita mulai dengan dua kali
hanya untuk melihat apa yang terjadi.
Nah, sebenarnya cukup
sederhana apa yang terjadi. Dengan menerapkan operasi controlled
U dua kali, kita secara efektif hanya
mengkuadratkan eigenvalue
karena itu akan ditendang ke dalam
phase qubit atas dua kali daripada hanya sekali.
Dan jadi ketika kita memikirkan
probabilitas hasil sebagai fungsi dari theta, kita pada dasarnya hanya
menggandakan frekuensinya.
Untuk setiap pilihan theta yang mungkin, probabilitas hasilnya
sama seperti yang akan terjadi kalau kita menggandakan theta dan kemudian
mengambil bagian pecahannya
untuk mendapatkan angka antara nol dan satu.
Misalnya, kalau theta
sama dengan satu setengah, maka eigenvalue-nya adalah negatif satu.
Jadi dengan menerapkan U dua kali kita secara efektif mengkuadratkan eigenvalue dan hasilnya sama seperti yang terjadi untuk theta sama dengan nol.
Yaitu bahwa probabilitas
untuk hasil nol, digambar dalam warna biru, sama dengan satu, dan probabilitas untuk hasil satu, digambar dalam warna ungu, sama dengan nol.
Ini sangat sederhana, tapi kita memang bisa mendapatkan
beberapa informasi tambahan tentang theta dengan melakukan ini.
Misalnya, kalau kita tahu sebelumnya bahwa theta sama dengan nol atau theta sama dengan satu perempat, maka circuit ini akan mengungkapkan kepada kita
mana dari dua kemungkinan itu.
Di sisi lain, kita tidak lagi bisa membedakan kasus theta sama dengan nol dari kasus theta sama dengan satu setengah.
Jadi prosedur ini tidak secara ketat lebih baik dari yang sebelumnya ketika
kita punya satu controlled U gate tapi dengan juga menjalankan circuit ini
kita bisa mendapatkan informasi tambahan.
Tidak langsung jelas
bagaimana informasi tambahan yang bisa kita dapatkan dengan mengiterasi operasi controlled U beberapa kali
bisa direkonsiliasi dengan
informasi yang kita dapatkan dengan melakukannya hanya sekali, dan sebenarnya ada beberapa
cara yang bisa kita lanjutkan.
Misalnya, ada teknik yang disebut iterative phase estimation, yang melibatkan menjalankan circuit seperti yang telah kita lihat,
bersama dengan beberapa variasi kecil pada mereka, untuk mendapatkan aproksimasi terhadap theta.
Tapi saya akan mendeskripsikan
apa yang bisa disebut pendekatan yang lebih tradisional, di mana kita menggunakan satu quantum circuit yang memiliki beberapa control qubit
yang mengontrol jumlah
iterasi yang berbeda dari operasi unitary U.
Pertama saya akan mendeskripsikan bagaimana ini
bekerja untuk dua control qubit dan kemudian nanti kita akan menggeneralisasikannya ke lebih dari dua control qubit.
Berikut quantum circuit
yang menggunakan dua control qubit.
Control qubit atas
mengontrol satu operasi U sementara qubit kedua dari atas
mengontrol dua salinan U.
Jadi yang kita lakukan adalah menggabungkan dua circuit yang kita lihat sebelumnya, dengan cara yang memanfaatkan satu salinan
dari eigenvector psi yang kita punya.
Namun kamu akan memperhatikan
bahwa Hadamard gate setelah operasi controlled U
telah dihapus dan belum ada pengukuran.
Yang akan kita lakukan adalah melihat
bagaimana circuit ini bekerja dan kemudian kita akan mencari tahu
apa yang harus kita lakukan dengan dua qubit atas
agar bisa mempelajari sebanyak mungkin tentang nilai theta yang
coba kita aproksimasi.
Setelah Hadamard gate dilakukan, kita mendapat state yang
ditunjukkan di layar.
WEBVTT
Dan ini akan menjadi cara yang nyaman untuk menulis state agar
bisa melihat apa yang terjadi selanjutnya.
A nol dan A satu adalah bit, dan kalau kita memikirkan dua qubit atas sebagai register dua qubit,
kita memikirkan A nol, yang bersesuaian dengan qubit atas sebagai bit yang kurang signifikan, dan A satu yang bersesuaian
dengan control qubit bawah
sebagai bit yang lebih signifikan.
Setelah operasi controlled U
pertama dilakukan, kita mendapatkan state ini.
State klasik yang bersesuaian dengan control qubit atas adalah a nol, jadi hasil dari phase kickback
bisa dinyatakan dengan cara ini. Kemudian setelah operasi controlled U kedua dan
ketiga dilakukan
kita mendapatkan state ini.
Idenya sama dengan yang pertama, kecuali kali ini kita menerapkan operasi control U dua kali.
Jadi kita mengalikan A satu dengan dua di
eksponen untuk mencerminkan ini.
Dan sekarang kita bisa menyederhanakan ekspresi ini dengan memikirkan bit-bit
A satu dan A nol bersama sebagai bilangan bulat antara nol dan
tiga menggunakan notasi biner.
Yaitu ketika kita memikirkan
string dua bit, A satu A nol, sebagai
pengkodean biner dari bilangan bulat,
yang kita dapatkan adalah dua
kali A satu ditambah A nol.
Dan pemahamannya adalah
bahwa ketika kita menulis Cat X, kita berbicara tentang X yang ditulis sebagai string biner dengan panjang
dua menggunakan notasi biner.
Jadi sekarang mari kita fokus pada
dua control qubit ini untuk mencari tahu apa yang
bisa kita pelajari tentang theta dari mereka saat ini.
N qubit yang tersisa masih
berada dalam state psi yang sama yang awalnya kita berikan, yang benar-benar merupakan hal yang luar biasa tentang pendekatan ini
karena seperti yang saya bilang sebelumnya, kita bisa menggunakan state itu lagi kalau kita ingin mendapatkan lebih banyak
informasi tentang theta.
Tapi untuk saat ini, mari kita hanya memikirkan apa yang bisa kita pelajari dari
dua control qubit ini.
Untuk membantu kita mencari tahu cara melanjutkan, mari kita bayangkan bahwa kita dijanjikan theta sama dengan Y per empat
untuk suatu bilangan bulat y antara nol dan tiga.
Secara umum, theta mungkin bukan
salah satu dari empat nilai ini, tapi ini adalah kasus alami untuk dipertimbangkan.
Kita lihat dalam versi satu control qubit asli dari prosedur bahwa kalau kita dijanjikan bahwa theta adalah nol atau satu setengah
circuit akan mengungkapkan mana yang benar. Dan kita juga memperhatikan bahwa dalam versi di mana kita menerapkan
operasi controlled U dua kali,
kita bisa memperfalak kasus theta sama dengan nol dari kasus theta
sama dengan satu perempat.
Jadi kita mungkin berharap bahwa dengan circuit baru kita bisa membedakan keempat kasus ini.
Pada intinya, yang
kita lakukan adalah menggunakan gagasan masalah promise
untuk membuat masalah lebih mudah, sehingga kita bisa melihat cara melanjutkan.
Dan itu bukan ide yang buruk, secara umum. Kalau kamu punya masalah dan kamu
tidak tahu cara menyelesaikannya, coba buat lebih mudah.
Kalau kamu bisa menyelesaikan masalah yang lebih mudah, wawasan yang kamu dapatkan mungkin berguna dalam menyelesaikan masalah yang lebih umum.
Dan kalau kamu tidak bisa menyelesaikan masalah yang lebih mudah, kamu mungkin belum siap
untuk masalah yang lebih umum.
Jadi terus buat lebih mudah
sampai kamu bisa menyelesaikannya.
Bagaimanapun, kembali ke masalah kita, mari kita definisikan state dua qubit untuk setiap nilai Y yang mungkin.
Dengan kata lain, phi Y sama dengan state
yang ditunjukkan di bagian atas layar ketika theta dipilih
secara spesifik sebagai Y per empat.
Dan berikut keempat
state tersebut ditulis secara eksplisit.
Jadi hanya untuk mengulang, kalau
theta sama dengan Y per empat untuk Y yang nol, satu, dua, atau
tiga dan kita menjalankan circuit kita,
kita akan tersisa dengan
salah satu dari keempat state ini, mana yang bersesuaian
dengan nilai Y yang tepat.
Dan kita hanya ingin mencari tahu
yang mana itu.
Dan pertanyaannya adalah, apakah ini mungkin?
Dan jawabannya adalah ya, karena keempat state ini ortogonal.
Kalau kamu menghitung inner product
antara pasangan manapun dari mereka, kamu akan mendapatkan nol.
Dan karena ortogonal, mereka bisa dibedakan secara sempurna oleh pengukuran projektif.
Dan khususnya kita bisa
menyatakan pengukuran seperti itu dengan mendefinisikan satu proyeksi untuk setiap vektor seperti yang ada di sini.
Ini selalu berhasil, kapanpun
kita punya basis ortonormal, dan kamu bisa memeriksa ini
terhadap definisi yang kita lihat di pelajaran tiga
untuk kasus spesifik ini
kalau kamu mau. Jadi kita menyimpulkan bahwa memang
mungkin untuk menyelesaikan tugas kita,
yaitu mempelajari nilai Y dari state yang ditunjukkan
di bagian atas layar.
Dan kalau kita ingin melakukan itu
dengan quantum circuit, kita bisa melanjutkan seperti yang akan saya jelaskan sekarang.
Pertama kita bisa mendefinisikan matriks unitary V yang kolomnya adalah empat
vektor yang terdaftar secara berurutan.
Matriks itu akan memiliki aksi yang dideskripsikan di bagian bawah layar,
pada state basis standar,
dan kita bisa menuliskan matriks
untuk melihat seperti apa tampilannya.
Karena V memetakan setiap state basis standar, kappa Y ke vektor phi Y, kita punya bahwa dengan menerapkan V dagger,
atau dengan kata lain V inverse ke phi Y akan mengubah kembali ke arah lain ke state basis standar yang bersesuaian.
WEBVTT
Jadi yang bisa kita lakukan adalah menerapkan V dagger ke state apapun yang kita
dapatkan dari circuit kita.
Dan kemudian kalau kita melakukan
pengukuran basis standar, kita akan mendapatkan angka Y
yang kita cari, dinyatakan sebagai string
dengan panjang dua dalam biner.
Sebelum kita melangkah lebih jauh, mari kita bicara sedikit lebih banyak
tentang matriks unitary V.
Ini adalah matriks yang istimewa dan
kamu mungkin pernah melihatnya sebelumnya.
Ini adalah matriks yang terkait
dengan operasi linear pada vektor empat dimensi yang dikenal sebagai discrete Fourier transform.
Lebih tepatnya, discrete Fourier transform bisa didefinisikan untuk
dimensi bilangan bulat positif apapun, dan kita akan melihatnya
secara umum dalam beberapa saat.
Dan beginilah tampilan
khususnya ketika dimensinya sama dengan empat.
Kita bisa memikirkan
discrete Fourier transform dengan cara yang berbeda.
Kita bisa memikirkannya secara abstrak murni sebagai pemetaan linear pada vektor yang bisa direpresentasikan oleh matriks.
Dan kita juga bisa memikirkannya sebagai masalah komputasional di mana kita diberi sebuah vektor, dan kita ingin menghitung hasilnya
dari penerapan pemetaan linear ini.
Itu ternyata menjadi masalah komputasional yang sangat penting,
dan ada algoritma yang sangat efisien untuk melakukan komputasi itu
yang dikenal sebagai fast Fourier transform.
Bahkan, ini adalah masalah yang sangat penting dalam pemrosesan sinyal misalnya, sehingga fast Fourier
transform dianggap oleh banyak orang
sebagai salah satu algoritma paling penting dan berpengaruh
yang pernah ditemukan.
Kita juga bisa memikirkan
discrete Fourier transform sebagai operasi kuantum unitary yang bisa diterapkan ke
vektor state kuantum.
Dan ketika kita memikirkannya dengan cara itu, kita menyebutnya quantum Fourier
transform, atau QFT singkatnya.
Secara matematis, ini pada dasarnya sama dengan discrete Fourier transform, tapi kita menyebutnya quantum Fourier transform
hanya untuk memperjelas bahwa ini adalah operasi yang diterapkan ke vektor state kuantum.
Jadi mari kita ubah nama matriks kita, dari V ke QFT empat untuk mencerminkan fakta
bahwa operasi yang kita dapatkan sebenarnya adalah quantum Fourier transform.
Jadi berikut circuit lengkap untuk mempelajari nilai Y ketika kita dijanjikan bahwa
theta sama dengan Y per empat
untuk Y yang nol, satu, dua, atau tiga.
Dan hanya untuk memastikan sudah jelas, kita menerapkan invers dari
quantum Fourier transform, atau dengan kata lain QFT empat dagger
untuk memetakan salah satu dari empat state yang mungkin kembali ke state basis standar, cat Y, sehingga kita bisa mendapatkan kembali Y dengan mengukur.
Jadi itulah circuit yang kita
dapatkan dari memikirkan versi promise dari
masalah phase estimation, di mana kita dijanjikan bahwa theta
adalah nol, satu perempat, satu
setengah, atau tiga perempat, tapi tidak ada yang mencegah kita
dari menjalankan circuit ini untuk
nilai theta sembarang.
Dan kalau kita melakukan itu, berikut
probabilitas untuk keempat hasil yang mungkin yang kita dapatkan.
Setiap dari empat nilai
yang mungkin untuk Y memiliki warnanya sendiri, dan plot memberitahu kita
apa probabilitas untuk masing-masing sebagai fungsi dari theta.
Jadi misalnya, kalau theta
sama dengan tiga perempat, kita akan mendapatkan hasil
tiga dengan probabilitas satu,
sedangkan probabilitas untuk tiga hasil lainnya semuanya nol seperti yang sudah kita ketahui dari memikirkan versi promise dari masalah.
Kalau theta mendekati tiga perempat tapi tidak tepat tiga perempat, akan ada beberapa probabilitas bukan nol yang terkait dengan hasil lainnya,
tapi kita masih akan mendapatkan hasil
tiga dengan probabilitas tinggi.
Jadi meskipun theta mungkin
tidak sama dengan Y per empat, kita masih bisa memikirkan
hasil yang kita dapatkan dari pengukuran dibagi empat
sebagai tebakan atau
aproksimasi untuk theta.
Tebakannya mungkin salah, tapi bagaimanapun itu
memberikan kita informasi.
Dan satu hal yang bisa kita
pelajari dari plot adalah bahwa aproksimasi terbaik selalu memiliki
probabilitas tertinggi yang terkait dengannya.
Ketika saya bilang aproksimasi terbaik, yang saya maksud adalah nilai Y per empat manapun yang paling dekat dengan nilai theta yang sebenarnya,
dalam pengertian modulo satu. Kasus terburuk adalah ketika theta berada tepat di tengah antara
dua nilai Y per empat.
Misalnya, kalau theta sama
dengan tiga per delapan atau 0,375, dalam kasus ini kita melihat
bahwa aproksimasi-aproksimasi
satu perempat dan dua perempat
atau satu setengah sama-sama bagus.
Jadi dalam kasus khusus
ini sebenarnya ada dua aproksimasi terbaik daripada satu.
Dan kita sama-sama mungkin mendapatkan hasil satu
dan hasil dua.
Dua hasil lainnya nol dan tiga, yang tidak memberikan aproksimasi yang sangat bagus
terhadap theta ketika kita bagi empat, memang muncul dengan beberapa probabilitas
yang tampaknya hanya
di bawah 10% dalam kedua kasus.
Jadi prosedur ini tidak sempurna, tapi memang memberikan kita informasi.
Dan patut dicatat bahwa
terlepas dari theta, kita selalu dijamin untuk mendapatkan aproksimasi terbaik
atau salah satu dari dua aproksimasi terbaik ketika ada seri, dengan probabilitas yang
tampaknya sedikit di atas 40%.
WEBVTT
Dan semakin dekat theta ke aproksimasi, semakin tinggi probabilitas untuk melihat nilai Y yang bersesuaian.
Dan itu peningkatan yang cukup
signifikan dibanding menggunakan satu control qubit.
Ini sebenarnya adalah prosedur
phase estimation ketika kita memilih untuk menggunakan dua control qubit.
Dan yang akan kita lakukan selanjutnya adalah menggeneralisasi prosedur ini
dengan cara yang alami, di mana kita tidak berhenti dengan
hanya dua control qubit
tapi kita menggunakan berapa banyak
control qubit yang kita pilih.
Dan yang akan kita lihat adalah bahwa dengan
menggeneralisasi prosedur, dengan menambahkan lebih banyak control qubit, kita akan bisa mendapatkan semakin banyak
aproksimasi yang akurat terhadap theta. Dan itu akan menjadi prosedur
phase estimation yang umum.
Agar bisa menggeneralisasi
prosedur phase estimation dari dua control qubit
ke berapa banyak pun yang kita pilih, kita perlu memahami
bagaimana quantum Fourier transform didefinisikan untuk dimensi lainnya.
Dan kita juga perlu mendiskusikan bagaimana bisa diimplementasikan
dengan quantum circuit.
Berikut definisi dari
quantum Fourier transform ketika dimensinya adalah
bilangan bulat positif N sembarang.
Di sini kita memikirkan operasi ini sebagai operasi pada sistem yang state klasiknya adalah
nol hingga N dikurangi satu.
Dan di sini matriks yang
mendeskripsikan operasi ini telah dinyatakan menggunakan
notasi langsung.
Kita juga bisa mendeskripsikannya dalam hal aksinya
pada state basis standar, hanya untuk menghubungkannya dengan
apa yang sudah kita lihat ketika N sama dengan empat.
Jadi beginilah tampilan
ketika N sama dengan satu, yang bukan kasus yang sangat menarik.
Berikut untuk N sama dengan dua, dan kamu akan memperhatikan apa yang kita dapatkan dalam kasus ini adalah operasi Hadamard.
Berikut quantum Fourier
transform untuk N sama dengan tiga.
Untuk N sama dengan empat, yang
sudah kita lihat.
Dan untuk satu contoh terakhir, beginilah ketika N sama dengan delapan.
Sama seperti yang kita punya sebelumnya
untuk kasus N sama dengan empat, inilah matriks yang kita kaitkan dengan discrete Fourier transform
untuk setiap dimensi. Tapi kita menyebutnya
quantum Fourier transform ketika kita ingin memikirkannya
sebagai operasi kuantum.
Terkadang ngomong-ngomong, faktor terdepan satu per akar kuadrat dari N tidak dimasukkan ketika kita memikirkan discrete Fourier
transform sebagai matriks,
tapi kita butuh faktor itu di sini untuk memastikan bahwa kita mendapatkan matriks unitary.
Terkadang juga ada tanda minus di setiap eksponen, tapi tidak selalu.
Ini pada dasarnya hanya preferensi pribadi yang tidak mengubah sifat fundamental
dari transformasinya.
Tapi bagaimanapun, kita akan mendefinisikan quantum Fourier transform seperti yang tertulis di layar.
Ada notasi singkatan yang sangat berguna
yang umum dan kita akan memanfaatkannya
nanti dalam pelajaran.
Dan itu adalah mendefinisikan
bilangan kompleks omega N, seperti yang kita punya di sini.
Secara khusus sebagai e pangkat dua pi I per N, yang juga bisa ditulis
menggunakan sinus dan kosinus
seperti yang ada di sini. Terkadang kita menyebut
angka ini sebagai akar N dari satuan karena ketika kita memangkatkannya
ke pangkat N, kita mendapatkan satu.
Berikut gambar yang menunjukkan beberapa contoh.
Omega satu sama dengan satu, omega dua sama dengan negatif satu, dan omega empat sama dengan I.
Secara umum untuk mendapatkan omega N, kita bisa membayangkan memotong lingkaran satuan menjadi N potongan berukuran sama seperti pizza yang dibagi oleh N orang
dan omega N berada di
sudut potongan pertama, dengan asumsi bahwa sudut lain
dari potongan itu berada di satu.
Jadi khususnya seiring N
semakin besar dan besar, potongan-potongannya akan semakin kecil dan kecil, dan omega N akan semakin
dekat dan dekat ke satu.
Dan sekarang kalau kita menggunakan notasi itu kita bisa menyatakan
quantum Fourier transform dengan cara yang sedikit lebih bersih.
Terkadang notasi ini
membantu menjaga hal-hal tetap sederhana seperti yang akan kita lihat terjadi
nanti dalam pelajaran.
Ada implementasi quantum circuit yang efisien dari quantum Fourier transform
ketika N adalah pangkat dua,
yang sekarang akan kita lihat. Meskipun kita cenderung mendefinisikan
quantum Fourier transform untuk dimensi N apapun,
kita hanya akan membutuhkannya
dalam kasus ketika N adalah pangkat dua, agar bisa menggeneralisasi
prosedur phase estimation.
Implementasinya akan menggunakan
controlled phase gate yang digambarkan seperti yang
ada di layar.
Tampilannya seperti dua
kontrol yang terhubung bersama dengan sebuah angka yaitu
alpha dalam kasus ini.
Dan aksi dari gate ini dideskripsikan oleh matriks yang ditunjukkan di sini.
Ini secara harfiah adalah
controlled phase gate, artinya kita punya control qubit yang mengontrol phase gate.
Kita melihat phase gate jauh di belakang di pelajaran satu.
Tapi untuk phase gate secara khusus, sebenarnya tidak masalah
qubit mana yang jadi kontrol dan mana yang jadi target.
Dan kita lihat itu di pelajaran dua, untuk kasus spesifik dari Z gate.
Dan sekarang kita sudah punya gagasan itu, kita bisa lanjut ke bagaimana
quantum Fourier transform bisa diimplementasikan.
WEBVTT
Implementasinya bersifat rekursif dan mungkin cara termudah untuk
mendeskripsikannya dengan sederhana adalah memberikan contoh yang
bisa dengan mudah digeneralisasikan.
Berikut caranya ketika N sama dengan 32.
Jadi ada lima qubit.
Untuk lebih jelasnya, kita mengasosiasikan
state basis standar dari lima qubit ini dengan bilangan bulat antara nol dan 31 menggunakan notasi biner.
Hal pertama yang kita lakukan adalah melakukan quantum Fourier
transform untuk N sama dengan 16 ke semua qubit kecuali
qubit paling tidak signifikan,
yang ada di bagian atas. Dan itulah bagian
rekursif dari konstruksinya.
Jadi untuk mengimplementasikan operasi ini, kita harus mengikuti pola yang sama tapi dengan satu qubit lebih sedikit.
Dan dalam kasus dasar kita
hanya punya satu qubit yang quantum Fourier transform-nya hanyalah Hadamard gate.
Setelah kita menerapkan QFT pada semua qubit kecuali yang atas, kita menerapkan sejumlah controlled phase gate menggunakan phase yang
ditunjukkan dalam diagram.
Kita kemudian menerapkan Hadamard
gate ke qubit atas, dan mengacak qubit-qubit sedikit menggunakan beberapa swap gate.
Swap gate ini memiliki efek perputaran siklik qubit-qubit yang diperlukan untuk membuat
konstruksinya bekerja.
Kita bisa mengikuti pola yang persis sama untuk pilihan N lainnya
asalkan mereka adalah pangkat dua, di mana kita selalu memulai controlled phase gate
dengan alpha menjadi pi per
dua untuk qubit terbawah dan dibagi dua setiap kali
bergerak ke kiri dalam diagram
untuk mendapatkan phase berikutnya. Sekarang sama sekali tidak jelas
bahwa konstruksi ini berhasil.
Dan saya tidak akan menjelaskan
kenapa berhasil dalam video ini.
Kalau kamu tertarik untuk melihat
detailnya kenapa berhasil, kamu bisa menemukannya di
konten tertulis untuk pelajaran.
Saya akan mengatakan bagaimanapun
bahwa yang dieksploitasi di sini adalah struktur dasar dari
discrete Fourier transform
dan sebenarnya itu adalah
struktur yang persis sama yang memungkinkan fast
Fourier transform untuk bekerja.
Cara lain untuk menyatakannya adalah bahwa kalau kita melihat fast Fourier transform, kita bisa memikirkannya dalam
konteks quantum circuit.
Dan inilah circuit yang kita dapatkan.
Jadi berapa banyak gate yang kita butuhkan secara total untuk implementasi ini?
Untuk mencari tahu itu, mari kita misalkan SM adalah jumlah gate yang
kita butuhkan ketika kita punya M qubit.
Ketika M sama dengan satu, kita hanya butuh satu gate karena QFT hanyalah operasi Hadamard dalam kasus ini.
Kalau M setidaknya dua, maka inilah
gate yang kita butuhkan.
Pertama kita butuh SM dikurangi satu gate untuk quantum Fourier
transform pada M dikurangi satu qubit, berapa pun jumlah itu.
Kita juga butuh M dikurangi satu
controlled phase gate, M dikurangi satu swap gate,
dan satu tambahan Hadamard gate.
Jadi berikut ekspresi
dari SM dalam kedua kasus ketika M sama dengan satu dan
ketika M setidaknya dua.
Ini adalah contoh dari apa yang disebut relasi rekurensi dan
mereka sangat umum muncul dalam analisis algoritma.
Yang satu ini
kebetulan sangat sederhana dan memiliki apa yang disebut
ekspresi bentuk tertutup, yang bisa kita dapatkan dengan menjumlahkan.
Lebih tepatnya, nilai SM adalah jumlah dari M
bilangan bulat ganjil pertama berturut-turut, yang sama dengan M kuadrat,
seperti yang mungkin pernah kamu temui sebelumnya atau mungkin kamu baru menyadarinya
di suatu titik dalam hidupmu.
Dan kebetulan cukup mudah untuk membuktikan rumus ini benar dengan induksi pada M kalau
kamu tertarik dengan bukti formal.
Jadi itulah. Kita bisa mengimplementasikan
quantum Fourier transform pada M qubit menggunakan M kuadrat gate.
Hanya beberapa catatan tambahan yang sangat
singkat.
Pertama kita sebenarnya tidak
butuh semua swap gate yang sudah saya deskripsikan.
Dimungkinkan untuk secara efektif
mendorong semuanya ke akhir selama kita menyesuaikan qubit mana yang dikerjakan oleh controlled phase gate
dengan tepat.
Dan kalau kita melakukan itu kita hanya akan
butuh M per dua swap gate secara total, dibulatkan ke bawah.
Kita masih akan memiliki biaya kuadratik, tapi jumlah gate bisa dikurangi dengan cara ini.
Dan satu catatan terakhir adalah bahwa kita sebenarnya bisa membuat biayanya bahkan lebih sedikit kalau kita mau menerima
aproksimasi yang cukup bagus.
Misalnya, ketika M semakin besar, banyak controlled phase gate yang cukup dekat dengan
operasi identitas,
dan menghilangkan
yang sangat dekat bisa menghemat kita cukup banyak pada gate sambil tetap memberi kita
aproksimasi yang cukup bagus.
Juga memungkinkan untuk mengaproksimasi quantum Fourier transform
dengan circuit yang sangat dangkal, artinya yang memiliki kedalaman kecil, kalau itu sesuatu
yang ingin kita lakukan.
Dan sekarang kita tahu apa
quantum Fourier transform untuk dimensi yang berbeda, serta bagaimana bisa diimplementasikan ketika dimensinya adalah pangkat dua,
kita bisa kembali ke
prosedur phase estimation dan melihat bagaimana bisa digeneralisasikan di mana kita menggunakan sejumlah
M control qubit yang sembarang.
Berikut tampilan prosedurnya sebagai quantum circuit untuk
pilihan M yang sembarang.
Kita punya M control qubit di atas, yang kita asumsikan semuanya
diinisialisasi ke state nol.
Kita menerapkan Hadamard
gate ke setiap satunya dan kemudian masing-masing digunakan sebagai control qubit untuk menerapkan beberapa pangkat dari
operasi unitary U,
WEBVTT
di mana kita menggandakan jumlah
kali U diterapkan untuk setiap control qubit.
Di sini dalam diagram ini saya telah menunjukkan ini dengan menyertakan pangkat
pada U di dalam kotak daripada menunjukkan controlled U gate
yang diterapkan sebanyak itu, sebagai cara untuk membuat
diagram lebih jelas dan menghemat ruang sehingga
pas di layar.
Sekarang hal pertama yang perlu kita perhatikan
tentang prosedur ini adalah bahwa mungkin menjadi sangat mahal.
Khususnya kita
menggandakan jumlah kali setiap operasi U diterapkan
untuk setiap control qubit.
Dan kalau cara yang kita lakukan ini adalah hanya mengiterasi controlled U gate berapa kali yang kita butuhkan,
kita akan mendapatkan circuit yang sangat besar. Akan
eksponensial besar dalam jumlah M.
Itu adalah keterbatasan besar secara umum, dan khususnya itu membatasi kemampuan kita untuk mendapatkan aproksimasi yang presisi
terhadap eigenvalue.
Dalam kasus khusus faktorisasi meskipun, yang akan kita bahas segera, ternyata kita sangat beruntung dan kita bisa memainkan trik yang memungkinkan kita
menghindari ledakan eksponensial dalam biaya ini.
Tapi secara umum untuk operasi unitary U yang sembarang, ini tidak akan mungkin dan
kita akan membayar harga yang mahal
untuk meningkatkan
jumlah control qubit.
Saya tidak akan melalui
analisis detail dari circuit dalam video ini dan sebaliknya saya hanya akan menyebutkan bahwa ada ekspresi yang cukup sederhana untuk state
tepat sebelum pengukuran yang ditunjukkan di layar.
Dari state itu kita bisa mendapatkan ekspresi untuk probabilitas
berbagai hasil, dan kebetulan terlihat seperti ini.
Dan begitu kita punya ekspresi ini,
kita bisa menalarnya, dan ekspresi ini
adalah semua yang kita butuhkan untuk melanjutkan.
Seperti yang saya bilang, saya tidak akan masuk ke
detailnya dalam video ini, tapi kamu bisa menemukannya di
konten tertulis untuk pelajaran dan ternyata tidak terlalu rumit,
jadi cek kalau kamu mau. Kalau kita memang melalui analisisnya, yang kita temukan adalah bahwa situasinya
tidak terlalu berbeda
dari kasus M sama dengan dua, kecuali bahwa kita mendapatkan lebih banyak presisi.
Khususnya, kita bisa memikirkan
pertama tentang probabilitas untuk mendapatkan aproksimasi yang paling baik atau salah satu
dari dua aproksimasi terbaik,
yang bisa kita nyatakan seperti yang ada di sini.
Kamu bisa mengabaikan subskrip satu pada nilai absolut kalau kamu mau.
Ini hanyalah simbol yang bisa kita
gunakan untuk mengingatkan diri sendiri bahwa kita sedang berbicara tentang
aproksimasi pada lingkaran di mana kita memikirkan theta sama dengan nol
dan theta sama dengan satu sebagai sama. Intinya di sini adalah bahwa
kita memikirkan pilihan Y apapun yang membuat Y per dua pangkat M
sedekat mungkin ke theta.
Dan sekali lagi, sama seperti yang kita
punya untuk kasus M sama dengan dua, kita dijamin mendapatkan hasil Y ini dengan probabilitas setidaknya 40%.
Bahkan, probabilitasnya adalah
setidaknya empat per pi kuadrat, yang sedikit lebih dari 40%.
10 bukan aproksimasi yang buruk
untuk pi kuadrat ketika kamu sedang terburu-buru.
Dan itu benar-benar luar biasa. Yang kita bicarakan adalah mendapatkan aproksimasi yang paling baik
terhadap theta sebagai pecahan Y per dua pangkat M
di mana Y adalah bilangan bulat. Dan kita mendapatkan
aproksimasi yang paling baik dengan probabilitas lebih dari 40%.
Kita juga bisa memikirkan
aproksimasi yang lebih buruk.
Secara khusus mari kita bayangkan
bahwa Y tidak cukup bagus, dan lebih spesifiknya mari kita misalkan
bahwa ada aproksimasi yang lebih baik
terhadap theta dari bentuk yang sama yang terletak antara theta dan Y per dua pangkat M,
yang bisa dinyatakan seperti
yang tertulis di layar.
Dalam kasus seperti itu
probabilitas untuk mendapatkan Y ini akan relatif kecil, paling banyak 25%.
Sebenarnya akan lebih rendah dari itu, tapi 25% adalah yang kita dapatkan dari
analisis yang cukup sederhana, tapi sudah cukup.
Sebagai contoh. Berikut plot yang kita dapatkan ketika kita menggunakan tiga control
qubit daripada dua.
Kali ini saya hanya
memplot probabilitas untuk hasil tiga, empat, dan lima karena saya tidak ingin
gambarnya terlalu berantakan.
Ketika theta sama dengan
satu setengah misalnya, kita dijamin mendapatkan hasil empat.
Dan jadi kita mengambil
aproksimasi kita sebagai empat per delapan atau satu setengah karena dua
pangkat tiga adalah delapan.
Dan dalam kasus ini kita tepat. Dan selama theta lebih dekat ke satu setengah daripada ke misalnya tiga
per delapan,
kita mendapatkan hasil empat dengan probabilitas lebih tinggi
daripada hasil tiga.
Dan dengan probabilitas,
lagi lebih besar dari 40%.
Berikut plotnya ketika M sama dengan empat. Dan kurva-kurvanya sebenarnya
terlihat hampir identik, kecuali bahwa sekarang kita telah memperbesar
sebesar faktor dua.
Jadi sekarang hasil yang diplot meliputi tujuh, delapan, dan sembilan dan kita mengambil aproksimasi sebagai salah satu dari angka-angka ini
dibagi 16 daripada delapan.
Dan saya akan menunjukkan satu plot lagi di mana kita meningkatkan ke M sama dengan lima.
Dan lagi kita akan
memperbesar sebesar faktor dua.
Dan inilah. Sekali lagi kurva-kurvanya terlihat
hampir identik, tapi kita secara efektif
menggandakan presisi kita.
WEBVTT
Dan seperti sebelumnya kita mendapatkan aproksimasi yang paling baik terhadap theta, dengan probabilitas lebih dari 40%.
Itu cukup luar biasa. Tapi kalau 40% tidak cukup bagus
sebagai ukuran kepercayaan,
yang bisa kita lakukan adalah menjalankan prosedur beberapa kali, dan
mengambil modus dari hasilnya, artinya yang paling sering muncul.
Dan kalau kita melakukan itu, kita akan sangat mungkin untuk mendapatkan aproksimasi yang sangat bagus terhadap theta.
Ingat ngomong-ngomong bahwa setiap kali kita menjalankan
prosedur phase estimation kita punya bahwa eigenvector
keluar tidak berubah.
Jadi itu tersedia bagi kita untuk menjalankan prosedur
beberapa kali seperti ini.
Singkatnya, kita mengumpulkan
statistik tentang theta, dan intinya adalah bahwa dengan melakukan ini kita bisa mendapatkan aproksimasi yang sangat presisi terhadap theta
dengan kepercayaan yang sangat tinggi, dan kita tidak butuh terlalu banyak iterasi dari prosedur untuk melakukan ini.
Dan itulah cara prosedur
phase estimation bekerja.
Di bagian terakhir pelajaran, kita akan menerapkan teknik
phase estimation ke masalah faktorisasi bilangan bulat.
Seperti yang saya sebutkan di awal video, cara kerjanya adalah kita mempertimbangkan masalah perantara yang dikenal sebagai masalah order finding.
Kita akan lihat bagaimana kita bisa menyelesaikan
masalah order finding menggunakan phase estimation, dan kemudian kita akan secara singkat mendiskusikan bagaimana menyelesaikan masalah order finding
memungkinkan kita memfaktorisasi bilangan bulat secara efisien.
Bagian kedua sepenuhnya klasik dan saya hanya akan merangkum ide
dasarnya dalam video ini.
Tapi mari kita mulai dengan
masalah order finding.
Pertama, mari kita siapkan
beberapa notasi yang berguna.
Untuk setiap bilangan bulat positif N, kita mendefinisikan ZN sebagai bilangan bulat
nol hingga N dikurangi satu.
Jadi misalnya, Z satu punya
satu elemen yaitu nol, Z dua punya elemen nol dan satu,
Z tiga punya elemen nol,
satu dan dua, dan seterusnya.
Jadi ZN adalah sebuah himpunan.
Tapi kita juga bisa memikirkannya
lebih dari sekadar himpunan. Kita bisa memikirkan operasi aritmatika seperti penjumlahan dan perkalian pada ZN
dengan mendefinisikannya modulo N.
Misalnya, misalkan
N sama dengan tujuh.
Kita punya bahwa tiga dan lima
adalah elemen dari Z tujuh dan kalau kita mengalikan mereka kita mendapatkan 15
yang menyisakan sisa
satu setelah dibagi tujuh.
Terkadang kita menyatakan ini dengan menulis bahwa tiga kali lima adalah
kongruen dengan satu modulo tujuh, seperti yang tertulis di sini.
Tapi kita juga bisa menulis saja bahwa tiga kali lima sama dengan satu.
Tentu saja tiga kali lima
biasanya tidak sama dengan satu, itu sama dengan 15.
Tapi ketika jelas bahwa
kita bekerja dalam Z tujuh artinya perkalian
didefinisikan modulo tujuh,
kita bisa menulis saja bahwa
tiga kali lima sama dengan satu.
Sekarang di antara elemen-elemen
ZN untuk N positif apapun, beberapa di antaranya akan memiliki
GCD sama dengan satu dengan N
dan beberapa tidak. Dan elemen-elemen yang memiliki GCD sama dengan satu dengan N itu istimewa.
dan kita menulis ZN bintang untuk merujuk pada himpunan elemen-elemen ini saja.
Jadi misalnya, berikut Z 21 bintang.
Di antara elemen-elemen Z 21, yang tentu saja ada 21, ternyata 12 di antaranya memiliki GcD sama dengan satu
dengan 21 dan sisanya tidak.
Khususnya setiap kali kita
punya elemen dari Z 21 yang habis dibagi tiga atau tujuh, kita lewati.
Ada berbagai alasan
kenapa himpunan ini istimewa, dan salah satu alasannya adalah bahwa setiap kali kita punya elemen dari ZN bintang
dan kita mempertimbangkan pangkat bilangan bulat positif dari angka itu, kita akan selalu akhirnya
sampai ke angka satu,
di mana sama seperti sebelumnya kita berbicara tentang perkalian modulo N.
pangkat bilangan bulat positif terkecil yang menghasilkan satu bagi kita disebut
order dari elemen itu.
Misalnya, pikirkan tentang elemen A sama dengan empat dalam Z 21 bintang.
empat kali empat adalah 16, yang tidak sama dengan satu modulo 21, tapi kalau kita mengalikan dengan empat satu kali lagi,
kita mendapatkan 64, dan 64 modulo
21 sama dengan satu.
Jadi order dari empat modulo 21 adalah tiga.
Mencapai satu seperti ini selalu terjadi untuk semua elemen dari ZN bintang.
Dan ngomong-ngomong, ini tidak pernah
terjadi untuk elemen ZN yang tidak ada dalam ZN bintang.
Jadi memiliki GCD sama dengan
satu dengan N seperti ini adalah kondisi yang perlu dan
cukup agar ini terjadi.
Dan hanya untuk menyelesaikan
contoh N sama dengan 21, berikut pangkat bilangan bulat positif terkecil untuk fungsi ini bekerja untuk
setiap elemen dari Z 21 bintang,
dan masing-masing bisa diperiksa satu per satu.
Dan sekarang kita bisa menyatakan
masalah order finding, yang hanya menemukan order untuk elemen yang diberikan dalam ZN bintang.
WEBVTT
Lebih tepatnya, inputnya adalah
dua bilangan bulat positif A dan N yang GCD-nya sama dengan satu,
dan outputnya adalah
bilangan bulat positif terkecil R sedemikian sehingga A pangkat R adalah
kongruen dengan satu modulo N,
atau secara ekuivalen
bilangan bulat positif terkecil R yang A pangkat R-nya sama dengan satu.
Dengan asumsi kita melakukan aritmatika dalam ZN.
Ini diyakini sebagai masalah yang
sulit secara komputasional, tidak ada algoritma klasik yang efisien
yang diketahui untuk menyelesaikannya.
Dan seperti yang akan kita diskusikan masalahnya setidaknya sama sulitnya dengan
faktorisasi bilangan bulat dalam artian bahwa kalau kita punya algoritma untuk menyelesaikan order finding,
kita akan dapat menggunakan algoritma itu untuk menyelesaikan masalah
faktorisasi bilangan bulat secara efisien.
Bahkan, itu juga berlaku sebaliknya, artinya kalau kamu kebetulan punya algoritma untuk faktorisasi, kamu bisa menggunakannya untuk menyelesaikan
masalah order finding.
Jadi kedua masalah itu
dalam beberapa hal setara dalam hal
kesulitan komputasionalnya.
Sekarang kita akan lihat bagaimana kita bisa menyelesaikan
masalah order finding pada komputer kuantum
menggunakan phase estimation.
Untuk membuat koneksi antara masalah-masalah itu, mari kita bayangkan bahwa kita punya sistem yang himpunan state klasiknya adalah AN.
Untuk pilihan elemen A manapun dalam ZN bintang, kita akan mendefinisikan operasi
MA seperti yang ada di sini.
Dalam kata-kata, yang MA lakukan adalah mengalikan dengan A, dan di sini perkaliannya modulo N.
Dan untuk sisa pelajaran ini, kamu harus selalu memikirkan
ekspresi di dalam cat sebagai dihitung modulo N,
hanya agar kita bisa menjaga hal-hal tetap sederhana dan kita tidak harus terus
menulis mod N berulang kali.
Ini adalah operasi unitary, tapi itu hanya benar
karena A ada dalam ZN bintang.
Kalau GCD dari A dan N bukan satu, operasi ini tidak akan unitary.
Berikut contohnya. Kalau N sama dengan 15 dan A sama dengan dua, yang ada dalam Z 15 bintang, maka
inilah aksi dari M dua.
Dan kalau kamu memeriksa
contoh ini beberapa saat, kamu akan melihat bahwa yang terjadi adalah elemen-elemen ZN hanya dipermutasikan oleh aksi ini.
Jadi ini bersifat deterministik dan unitary, artinya sebagai matriks, MA adalah matriks permutasi.
Dan inilah ide utamanya. Eigenvalue dari MA sangat erat terhubung
dengan order dari A. Dan dengan menggunakan phase estimation untuk mengaproksimasi eigenvalue-eigenvalue ini cukup dekat
kita bisa menentukan order dari A. Jadi apa sebenarnya eigenvector dan eigenvalue dari MA?
Nah, kita tidak akan butuh semuanya, kita hanya butuh beberapa saja.
Mari kita mulai dengan contoh yang mudah.
Berikut eigenvector dari MA, kita namai psi nol, dan diberikan oleh
jumlah dari cat satu, cat a,
cat A kuadrat, dan seterusnya hingga cat A pangkat R dikurangi satu, semuanya dibagi dengan akar kuadrat dari R
untuk membuatnya menjadi vektor satuan. Di sini R adalah order dari A.
Dan saya akan menyimpan
huruf R untuk order dari A untuk sisa pelajaran.
Jadi setiap kali kamu melihat R, itu adalah order dari A untuk
A apapun yang kita bicarakan.
Eigenvalue yang terkait
dengan eigenvector ini adalah satu.
Dan kita bisa memverifikasinya dengan
menerapkan MA ke vektor ini untuk melihat apa yang kita dapatkan.
MA mengalikan dengan A, jadi
kita hanya perlu meningkatkan setiap eksponen sebesar
satu dan inilah yang kita dapatkan.
Tapi order dari A adalah R, jadi A pangkat R sama dengan satu.
Dan kita bisa membuat substitusi itu.
Tapi itu adalah vektor yang sama
yang kita mulai. Yang sudah kita lakukan hanyalah
mengacak cat-cat di sekitarnya tapi kita mengambil jumlah sehingga
ini tidak mengubah apa pun.
Jadi MA kali psi nol sama dengan psi nol.
Jadi itu adalah eigenvector dari
MA dengan eigenvalue satu.
Itu adalah contoh yang sangat sederhana
dari eigenvector dan untuk mengidentifikasi lebih banyak dari mereka, mari kita ingat kembali notasi yang sama yang kita punya sebelumnya dalam pelajaran.
Omega R adalah bilangan
kompleks pada lingkaran satuan yang kita dapatkan dengan mengambil E pangkat
dua kali pi kali I
dibagi dengan R. Terakhir kali kita punya N daripada R, tapi cara kerjanya masih sama
untuk R menggantikan N.
Kita butuh angka ini karena
itu akan muncul dalam eigenvector-eigenvector lain
dari MA yang akan kita identifikasi.
Dan sekarang kita sudah mengingat notasi itu, kita bisa mengamati bahwa
vektor bernama psi satu ini juga merupakan eigenvector dari MA.
Mirip dengan psi nol, kita punya persis cat yang sama dan kita menjumlahkan mereka dan
membagi dengan akar kuadrat dari R.
Tapi kali ini kita punya berbagai fase yang mengalikan setiap cat.
Omega R pangkat negatif satu untuk A, omega R pangkat negatif dua untuk A kuadrat, dan seterusnya hingga omega R pangkat
negatif R dikurangi satu
untuk A pangkat R dikurangi satu. Jadi pangkat omega R
selalu negatif satu kali pangkat A apapun yang
muncul di dalam cat.
Saya tidak akan melaluinya secara detail, tapi itu ditunjukkan di layar kalau kamu ingin menonton ulang video dan menjeda sesuai kebutuhan.
Tapi kalau kita melakukan perkalian dan kita menyederhanakan lagi menggunakan fakta bahwa A pangkat R sama dengan satu
serta fakta yang sangat penting bahwa omega pangkat R sama dengan satu, yang akan kita temukan adalah bahwa kita
lagi punya eigenvector dari MA.
WEBVTT
Kali ini saat kita melakukan penyederhanaan, kita perlu menarik keluar faktor omega R untuk melihat bahwa memang kita punya eigenvector
dan bahwa omega R itu mewakili eigenvalue yang terkait dengan eigenvector ini.
Jadi itu adalah pasangan eigenvector
eigenvalue kedua dari NA.
Kita bisa mengidentifikasi eigenvector-eigenvector tambahan menggunakan penalaran yang persis sama, Dan sebenarnya, kalau kita cukup gantikan omega R
dengan omega R pangkat J untuk setiap J antara nol dan R dikurangi satu, kita akan selalu mendapatkan eigenvector,
dan eigenvalue yang terkait akan menjadi omega R pangkat J.
Jadi ini sebenarnya mencakup
psi nol dan psi satu, yang sudah kita lihat
serta R dikurangi dua, pasangan eigenvector eigenvalue lainnya.
Semuanya bekerja pada dasarnya dengan cara yang sama, dan untuk memverifikasinya, kita hanya perlu tahu bahwa A pangkat R sama dengan satu
serta omega R pangkat
R sama dengan satu.
Ada eigenvector-eigenvector lain dari MA seperti cat nol misalnya, tapi mereka tidak akan berguna bagi kita dan kita tidak perlu mengkhawatirkan mereka.
Kita hanya perlu mengkhawatirkan psi nol hingga psi R dikurangi satu.
Mari fokus pada psi satu sejenak, hanya untuk mencoba memahami kenapa kita peduli tentang eigenvector-eigenvector ini
dan apa yang bisa mereka ceritakan
kepada kita tentang order R, yang coba kita temukan.
Misalkan kita diberi
eigenvector psi satu, kita bisa mencoba untuk mempelajari
R dengan cara berikut.
Pertama, kita melakukan phase
estimation pada eigenvector ini menggunakan quantum circuit yang
mengimplementasikan operasi MA.
Yang kita dapatkan adalah aproksimasi terhadap theta, yang dalam kasus ini adalah satu per R.
Dan kedua karena kita mencari R dan kita punya
aproksimasi terhadap satu per R, hal alami yang harus dilakukan adalah
menghitung resiprokal
dan membulatkannya ke bilangan bulat
terdekat. Kita harus membulatkan seperti ini
karena R harus bilangan bulat.
Tapi kita tidak punya satu per R secara tepat, kita hanya punya aproksimasi terhadapnya.
Tapi kalau aproksimasi cukup bagus, kita akan mendapatkan R ketika kita membulatkan,
yang merupakan yang kita cari.
Dan sekarang pertanyaannya adalah berapa banyak presisi yang kita butuhkan untuk menentukan R dengan benar dengan menghitung resiprokal dan membulatkan?
Atau dengan kata lain, seberapa akurat aproksimasi kita perlu
agar semuanya berhasil?
Nah, ternyata kita memang butuh aproksimasi yang cukup akurat.
Misalnya, kita tidak boleh
membingungkan satu per R dengan satu per R ditambah satu, atau satu per R dikurangi satu misalnya.
Kedua pecahan itu, satu per R ditambah satu dan
satu per R dikurangi satu cukup dekat ke satu
per R ketika R besar.
Tapi meskipun kita butuh
aproksimasi yang cukup akurat, kita tidak butuh aproksimasi yang sangat akurat, dan bisa ditunjukkan bahwa
kalau aproksimasi kita
memenuhi ketidaksetaraan yang
ada di layar, maka pembulatan
akan memberikan kita jawaban yang benar.
Saya tidak akan mencoba untuk membuktikan itu dalam video ini, tapi ditunjukkan dalam
materi tertulis untuk pelajaran kalau kamu tertarik dengan detailnya.
Dan kalau itulah akurasi
yang kita tuju, maka cukup menggunakan jumlah control qubit dalam prosedur phase estimation
yang sama dengan dua kali
panjang N ditambah satu.
Di mana seperti yang kita punya di pelajaran sebelumnya, panjang N adalah jumlah bit yang kita butuhkan untuk menyatakan N dalam biner.
Ngomong-ngomong, kalau kita puas
mendapatkan aproksimasi terbaik dengan probabilitas setidaknya 40% dan kita tidak mencoba untuk
meningkatkan kepercayaan kita
seperti yang saya deskripsikan sebelumnya, maka kita sebenarnya tidak butuh tambahan satu.
Tapi bagaimanapun, kita punya bahwa jumlah
control qubit yang kita butuhkan adalah linear dalam panjang N
yang ditulis sebagai string biner.
Kita sudah melihat bahwa kalau kita punya
eigenvector psi satu, kita bisa menggunakan phase estimation untuk menemukan R, asalkan kita menggunakan akurasi yang cukup.
Sayangnya tidak semudah itu untuk mendapatkan eigenvector ini.
Jadi mari kita ajukan pertanyaan yang berbeda.
Misalkan kita tidak punya psi satu, tapi justru kita punya psi
untuk pilihan J yang acak.
Bisakah kita tetap mencari tahu apa R-nya? Atau setidaknya bisakah kita
mencari tahu sesuatu tentang R?
Dan jawabannya adalah ya, kita bisa mencari tahu sesuatu
tentang R, setidaknya rata-rata.
Yang bisa kita lakukan adalah mencoba
untuk mencari tahu J per R menggunakan metode yang sangat mirip
dengan yang baru kita lihat,
tapi dengan perbedaan penting.
Pertama, kita akan melakukan persis
hal yang sama yang kita lakukan sebelumnya, yaitu menjalankan prosedur
phase estimation pada eigenvector psi J.
Dan yang akan kita dapatkan adalah
aproksimasi terhadap J per R, bukan satu per R,
seperti yang kita punya sebelumnya.
Tapi sekarang kita punya masalah kecil, karena menghitung
resiprokal tidak akan memberikan kita R, itu akan memberikan kita R per J.
Dan ngomong-ngomong, kita tidak
berasumsi bahwa kita tahu apa J-nya, kita hanya diberi psi J untuk J yang acak,
dan kita tidak diberitahu apa J-nya. Jadi apa yang bisa kita lakukan?
Nah, ternyata ada algoritma
klasik yang terkenal yang bisa membantu kita, yang disebut
continued fraction algorithm.
Dan yang bisa dilakukan algoritma ini adalah mengambil aproksimasi kita
Y per dua pangkat M dan memberitahu kita pecahan mana U per V,
ditulis dalam bentuk paling sederhana, dan di mana U dan V keduanya
bilangan bulat yang lebih kecil dari N paling dekat dengan aproksimasi kita.
WEBVTT
Ini benar-benar algoritma yang menakjubkan, dan kalau kamu tertarik dengannya, kamu harus mengeceknya.
Ini sangat erat terhubung dengan algoritma Euclid untuk
menghitung GCD sebenarnya.
Tapi saya tidak akan mengatakan apa pun
lagi tentangnya dalam video ini.
Intinya adalah bahwa kalau kita punya
aproksimasi yang bagus untuk beberapa pecahan yang pembilang dan
penyebutnya tidak terlalu besar,
algoritma bisa memulihkan pecahan itu, dan itulah yang kita lakukan di sini.
Dan sekarang kita tersisa dengan persis
pertanyaan yang sama seperti sebelumnya, yaitu berapa banyak presisi yang kita butuhkan?
Dan ternyata
batas yang persis sama yang kita punya sebelumnya berlaku dalam kasus ini.
Dan jadi memilih M dengan cara yang persis sama
seperti sebelumnya juga berhasil di sini.
Sekarang ini tidak selalu
akan memberi tahu kita R.
Yang akan kita pelajari kalau kita menggunakan
cukup presisi, adalah J per R, tapi itu akan menjadi
pecahan dalam bentuk paling sederhana.
Jadi kita mungkin tidak beruntung dalam artian bahwa pilihan J yang acak ini bisa memiliki faktor persekutuan dengan R,
dan mereka akan tersembunyi dari kita. Dalam kasus terburuk misalnya, kita bisa mendapatkan J sama dengan nol dan kita tidak akan mempelajari apa pun sama sekali.
Tapi itu secara harfiah satu-satunya
kasus di mana kita tidak mempelajari apa pun.
Secara umum, kita setidaknya akan
mendapatkan faktor yang tidak sepele dari R, dan kalau kita bisa mengambil sampel acak
dan mendapatkan psi J untuk pilihan J yang berbeda, kita sebenarnya bisa memulihkan
R dengan probabilitas tinggi dengan menghitung kelipatan persekutuan terkecil
dari semua penyebut
yang kita amati. Dan ini sebenarnya tidak
memerlukan sangat banyak sampel sama sekali.
Intinya adalah bahwa beberapa pilihan J akan menyembunyikan faktor-faktor R, tapi pilihan J yang acak
tidak akan bisa menyembunyikan
faktor-faktor R untuk waktu yang lama.
Jadi itulah idenya. Yang tersisa adalah mempertimbangkan implementasinya dan khususnya untuk mencari tahu
berapa biayanya.
Inti dari ide ini, untuk menghitung order dari
elemen A yang diberikan di ZN bintang adalah menerapkan prosedur phase estimation
ke operasi MA.
Mari kita cari tahu apa
biaya untuk melakukan ini sebagai fungsi dari panjang N huruf besar, yang akan saya lambangkan dengan n huruf kecil.
Berikut circuit untuk phase estimation. Kita akan butuh n huruf kecil qubit di bagian bawah circuit
untuk mengkodekan elemen ZN dalam biner. Jadi kita punya N control qubit di atas dan n huruf kecil qubit di bawah,
yang bagus karena itu cocok dengan nama-nama yang
kita gunakan sebelumnya dalam pelajaran.
Untuk menghitung
jumlah gate yang kita butuhkan untuk keseluruhan circuit, mari kita fokus terlebih dahulu pada biaya operasi unitary terkontrol.
Kalau kita menggunakan teknik
dari pelajaran sebelumnya, pelajaran enam, kita bisa mengimplementasikan MA menggunakan O besar dari n huruf kecil kuadrat gate
menggunakan algoritma klasik yang efisien untuk aritmatika modulo N.
Saya akan melewati detailnya dalam video ini, tapi seperti beberapa hal lain
yang sudah saya bicarakan, kamu bisa membaca lebih banyak tentangnya di materi tertulis untuk pelajaran.
Tapi tidak cukup
untuk hanya mengimplementasikan MA.
Kita juga perlu mengimplementasikan MA kuadrat, MA pangkat empat,
pangkat delapan, dan seterusnya
sampai MA ke pangkat yang eksponensial dalam M.
Dan kita tahu kita perlu mengambil M linear dalam n huruf kecil
untuk mendapatkan cukup presisi.
Ini adalah kekhawatiran besar,
dan saya sampaikan sebelumnya.
Kalau kita mengimplementasikan pangkat
MA dengan hanya mengiterasi MA, kita akan bermasalah karena semua iterasi MA ini
akan menimbulkan biaya eksponensial.
Untungnya, kita bisa memainkan trik untuk menghindari ledakan biaya ini.
Yang bisa kita lakukan adalah sebagai berikut, untuk setiap pangkat K yang kita butuhkan.
Pertama, kita hitung A pangkat
K, modulo N.
Ini adalah masalah modular exponentiation yang saya sebutkan di pelajaran enam.
Dan bisa diselesaikan secara efisien. Dan ini adalah sesuatu yang bisa kita lakukan dengan komputer klasik.
Komputasi ini tidak
perlu dilakukan oleh quantum circuit sama sekali.
Jadi mari kita biarkan B menjadi hasilnya.
Jadi B adalah elemen dari ZN bintang.
Dan kedua, sebagai pengganti MA pangkat K, kita cukup menggunakan circuit untuk MB.
Dan itulah saja. B hanyalah elemen dari ZN bintang, jadi biaya untuk mengimplementasikan MB
adalah O besar dari n huruf kecil kuadrat.
Singkatnya, yang kita lakukan adalah eksponensiasi dalam ZN daripada mengeksponensiasi
quantum circuit.
Tapi operasi aktual yang kita
dapatkan adalah sama dalam kedua cara. Itu hanya perkalian dengan A, K kali.
Ini semacam keajaiban sebenarnya. Dan kita tidak akan dapat
menyelesaikan masalah order finding atau memfaktorisasi bilangan bulat secara efisien
dengan komputer kuantum
kalau bukan karena ini.
Dan sekarang kita tahu bahwa setiap operasi unitary terkontrol, termasuk pangkat-pangkatnya, bisa diimplementasikan
dengan biaya O besar dari n kuadrat, kita bisa menghitung total
jumlah gate yang kita butuhkan.
Kita punya N Hadamard gate, dan karena M sama dengan
O besar dari n huruf kecil, biayanya adalah O besar dari n huruf kecil.
WEBVTT
Kita punya M operasi unitary terkontrol yang masing-masing memiliki biaya O besar dari N kuadrat.
Jadi total biaya di sini
adalah O besar dari N pangkat tiga.
Dan akhirnya, quantum Fourier transform memiliki biaya O besar dari n kuadrat.
Jadi total biayanya adalah O besar dari N pangkat tiga.
Khususnya, kita melihat bahwa bahkan dengan trik
modular exponentiation kita, biaya operasi unitary terkontrol mendominasi.
Tapi bagaimanapun, biayanya
adalah polinomial dalam n huruf kecil.
Ada juga beberapa
komputasi klasik yang diperlukan, seperti menghitung modular exponentiation dan menjalankan continued
fraction algorithm,
tapi komputasi-komputasi itu
juga memiliki biaya polinomial. Dan bahkan, mereka bisa dilakukan dalam O besar dari N pangkat tiga operasi juga.
Hanya tersisa satu masalah, yaitu bahwa kita perlu mendapatkan salah satu dari eigenvector-eigenvector ini.
Bagaimana kita bisa melakukan ini?
Solusinya sebenarnya sangat sederhana. Kita tidak menjalankan circuit
pada eigenvector.
Kita hanya menjalankannya pada state satu, artinya pengkodean biner dari angka satu, yang kita pikirkan
sebagai elemen dari ZN.
Jadi mari kita buat
penggantian itu dalam diagram.
Alasan ini berhasil adalah karena persamaan ini di sini.
State cat satu sebenarnya adalah
superposisi seragam dari R eigenvector yang
sudah kita bicarakan.
Dan itu tidak langsung jelas, tapi kalau kamu menghitung
jumlahnya, kamu seharusnya mendapatkan cat satu.
Dan kalau kita menjalankan circuit pada state ini, output yang kita dapatkan
akan persis sama seolah-olah kita memilih J secara acak
dan menjalankan prosedur pada
eigenvector psi J.
Sekali lagi, itu tidak jelas, tapi analisis mengungkapkan bahwa itu benar.
Dan akhirnya, itulah. Kita punya algoritma kuantum yang efisien
untuk order finding.
Tersisa satu bagian yang sangat singkat
dari pelajaran dan itu berkaitan dengan hubungan antara faktorisasi bilangan bulat
dan order finding.
Saya menyebutkan bahwa kalau kita bisa menyelesaikan masalah order finding secara efisien, maka kita juga bisa memfaktorisasi
bilangan bulat secara efisien.
Dan saya ingin secara singkat memberikan kamu ide utama tentang bagaimana ini bekerja.
Ini sepenuhnya klasik. Bagian ini sebenarnya tidak
ada hubungannya dengan quantum computing.
Berikut metode untuk menemukan
faktor yang tidak sepele dari bilangan bulat positif N yang diberikan.
Dan ngomong-ngomong, metode ini hanya berhasil ketika N adalah bilangan ganjil, dan bukan
bilangan prima yang dipangkatkan.
Dua kasus itu ketika N
adalah genap atau pangkat prima bisa ditangani secara terpisah.
Ada metode klasik yang efisien untuk mendeteksi dan
menangani kedua kasus itu.
Metode ini bersifat probabilistik. Mungkin gagal, tapi
probabilitas kegagalan akan paling banyak setengah,
dan kita bisa menjalankannya
beberapa kali secara independen untuk mengurangi probabilitas
kesalahan secara eksponensial cepat.
Pertama, kita pilih A antara
dua dan N dikurangi satu secara acak, seragam.
Kemudian kita hitung GCD dari A dan N.
Dan kalau GCD kebetulan
lebih besar dari satu, maka kita baru saja sangat beruntung.
GCD akan menjadi faktor dari N dan kita bisa langsung mengeluarkannya dan berhenti.
Kalau tidak, algoritma berlanjut dan kita sekarang tahu bahwa A ada dalam ZN bintang.
Dan sekarang kita menghitung order dari A, di situlah kita butuh komputer kuantum.
Atau mungkin kita punya cara berbeda
untuk menghitung ordernya. Algoritma tidak benar-benar
peduli dari mana asalnya, tapi satu-satunya cara yang kita tahu
bagaimana melakukan ini secara efisien
adalah dengan komputer kuantum.
Kalau order R adalah genap, maka kita menghitung GCD dari
A pangkat R per dua dikurangi satu dengan N.
Dan kalau GCD itu lebih besar dari satu, maka lagi kita punya faktor dari N, jadi kita keluarkan dan kita berhenti.
Kalau tidak algoritma telah gagal. Dan dalam kasus itu, kita
bisa kembali ke awal dan memilih A yang berbeda
dan berharap hasilnya lebih baik
kali ini.
Dan itulah. Dan ngomong-ngomong, begitu
kita menemukan faktor dari N, kita bisa merekurs pada faktor itu
dan membaginya dengan faktor itu sampai kita punya faktorisasi prima dari N.
Jadi kenapa ini harus berhasil?
Nah, ada dua poin utama. Yang pertama adalah bahwa karena A pangkat R kongruen dengan satu modulo N,
kita punya bahwa N membagi A
pangkat R dikurangi satu.
Kedua pernyataan itu
sebenarnya setara. Ini adalah definisi mod N yang akan kamu temukan di buku-buku teori bilangan.
Kedua, kalau R genap, maka persamaan yang
ada di sini benar.
Ini adalah rumus yang terkenal
untuk selisih kuadrat.
Sebenarnya, persamaannya benar untuk semua R, tapi kita butuh R per dua menjadi
bilangan bulat di langkah empat.
WEBVTT
Dan jadi kalau kita menggabungkan dua fakta itu, kita melihat bahwa setiap faktor prima dari N harus membagi salah satu dari dua
ekspresi dalam tanda kurung,
karena itulah satu-satunya cara
agar N bisa membagi produknya.
Sekarang, bisa saja bahwa setiap
faktor prima dari N membagi ekspresi pertama dalam tanda kurung dan bukan yang kedua, tapi untuk A acak kita,
itu tidak terlalu mungkin. Dan jadi ketika kita menghitung
GCD di langkah empat, kemungkinan besar kita akan mendapatkan produk
dari beberapa faktor prima
dari N, tapi tidak semuanya.
Untuk menganalisis ini dengan cermat
membutuhkan beberapa teori bilangan, tapi itu adalah teori bilangan yang cukup dasar.
Jadi kalau kamu menemukan teori bilangan menarik dan ingin mempelajari lebih lanjut tentangnya, coba bekerja melalui analisis ini.
Mengerjakan hal-hal seperti ini adalah cara yang sangat bagus untuk mempelajari lebih banyak, tapi saya akan serahkan itu padamu.
Dan itulah akhir dari pelajaran. Dalam pelajaran ini, kita membahas
masalah phase estimation, bagaimana kita bisa menyelesaikannya secara efisien
pada komputer kuantum,
dan bagaimana kita bisa menerapkan solusi untuk mendapatkan algoritma kuantum berbiaya polinomial untuk faktorisasi bilangan bulat.
Saya harap kamu akan bergabung dengan saya untuk pelajaran berikutnya, yaitu tentang algoritma
pencarian kuantum Grover.
Sampai jumpa.